non mais si vous en avez d'autres vous
pouvez nous les transférer par internet
tout de suite à l'association des maires
ruraux de haute saône c'est
l'effervescence depuis quelques jours
sur la centaine de communes qui ont
ouvert leurs portes début décembre pour
recueillir les doléances de leurs
administrés une soixantaine ont déjà
fait remonter leurs premiers cahiers
moins de deux semaines
donc après le début de cette initiative
dans les mairies les gens ils ont besoin
de parler de s'exprimer d'échanger sur
sur plane sujet est tellement longtemps
qu'on ne les a pas considérer un au
moins un petit peu et c'est justement là
la sonnette d'alarmé que les maires
ruraux des rayons depuis si longtemps
donc aujourd'hui que les nos concitoyens
puissent s'exprimer au plus près le pré
2 c'est le sens de la démocratie locale
l'association des maires ruraux de
france centralise l'ensemble des
doléances dans ses bureaux à lyon
le retour est déjà acté pour une
trentaine de départements et il est
possible de dresser déjà un premier état
des lieux
ce qui revient c'est la justice sociale
la justice fiscale la transition
écologique et énergétique l'organisation
politique et territorial le rôle de
l'état dans les territoires
le rôle de l'état dans les territoires
la proximité c'est les services
c'est ce qu'on dénonce depuis longtemps
l'aménagement le transport et la
mobilité des doléances transmises en
haute saône au préfet du département qui
va les recevoir
une initiative des maires ruraux mais
qui va marquer le début d'un calendrier
souhaité par le président de la
république à partir de mi janvier
le grand débat national va se lancer
avec un certain nombre de thématiques
assez large la transition des taxes le
débat démocratique etc
et puis mi-mars qui s'achève et puis mi
avril des décisions seront annoncées un
calendrier défini avec des cahiers de
doléances qui vont servir de base de
travail pour les prochaines semaines